all right thank you so yeah I gave a
similar talk here in August yeah if you
were here but this time there will be
some overlap but I would try to make it
more general and like 200 on my open
problems at you hoping that something
will happen so the main theme of this
talk would be that boolean function that
has simple Fourier transform also have
small complexity okay can you see this
red whatever and obviously there are
various way to interpret this statement
right you can measure the complexity of
the Fourier transform of the function in
several ways and you can also think of
many different computational models by
which you are constrict you measure the
complexity of a function so we'll get
we'll get to it will define whatever
needs to be fine I should also mention
that there are many results also in the
other direction where you choose
function with small complexity and you
show properties of the Fourier spectrum
like little degree concentration or
stuff like that but I'm going to talk
about taking function that the Fourier
transform behaves in a special way not
what you would expect from a random
function and then see what we can say
about its complexity so let's just
figure out what we're going to do so the
first type of functions I will speak
about this function with small spectral
norm which I will define and what can
you say about the sake of complexity and
the decision tree model and the second
type of functions those are boolean
function who have very few nonzero
fourier coefficients which we also
relate to communication complexity and
decision trees so everything will be
defined so hopefully it will be okay so
just to get my yarn notation clear so
we're looking at the the vector space of
function from this group C 2 to the N
into the real numbers and then you have
the Fourier characters there
chi Chi alpha of X is just minus 1/2 the
inner product with Alpha X then you
write if we function as a linear
combination of those functions this is
all standard and obviously then we're
interested in moving functions that is
functions that only take the value is
plus and minus 1 so so it's a bit
natural to to figure out that obviously
not not every linear combination of it
not every linear combination of those
function I will give you a boolean
function and it has to be rather special
linear combination to for the function
to take only only the values plus n
minus 1 I mean not just any unique
combination combination you would pick
up off the street we do it you have to
be some structure must must be there if
you want a function to be boolean so
let's define the just specular norm or
the l1 norm of such a function for
boolean function which is just the sum
and absolute value of the fovea
coefficient for example the l2 norm is
always 1 right that's the Possible's
theorem and the other one known can be
large it can be as high as 2 to the N
over 2 and it forced some function
tester that's the number and of a random
function if we just for every vector in
Z to the N you just keep echoing and
decide one or minus one then it's going
to be large something exponentially n so
the question is what when is it small I
mean what does it mean for a boolean
function to have a small spectral norm
so here's that a nice collection of such
function which are indicators of our of
subspaces of Z to the N or subgroups so
if F is an indicator function or
characteristic function of such a
subspace then inspector norm is burdened
by a constant which happens to be 3 but
I get by an indicator function I mean
that it is minus minus 1 is the true
value of the boolean function so it is
not obviously doesn't matter so it is
minus 1 inside the subspace and 1
everywhere else
so it's better on me that most three and
they are so just a few example that the
end function is not that's not the
common way you would think about the end
function but it just indicated one point
so it's it's a shift of the zero
subspace in the or function and the XOR
function are also all such functions and
for for all such functions again the l1
norm is at most three now obviously if
you take a linear combination of such a
short linear combination of such
function you would also get function
with small spectral norm and it turns
out to be essentially the only case so
here is our theorem by painting Sanders
which said that suppose F is some
boolean function we have mu star and one
on bottom by M and it's just some real
number then you couldn't you can write
this function as some on plus and minus
one of indicators of the indicators
appear in such bases or curse sets and L
is bounded by this two to the two to the
oath M to the fourth so as scary as it
might seem it still it doesn't depend on
n right it only depends on M so the only
way you can construct a family function
with constant spectral norm is by taking
a linear combination of constantly many
indicators so may notice this oval gives
you something computational about such
functions so let's uh let's define this
complexity class a c0 with two here's
the class of boolean function which can
be computed by circuits with polynomial
number of gates the death is constant
and you have unbounded fanon and or not
and parity gates
those are your building blocks the the
usual end or not and you also have a mod
to get mod to gate so so by this result
if we inside as you only get that if M
is over one function with constants
flexible norm are in fact in AC zero
with mod two gates which is kind of nice
because
we know we can do without the more to
get right we know X or of n variables is
not with in AC zero and its spectrum is
one but once we add those Montu gates
this parity case we get all Oh pump
function of constant spectrum known for
so I'll just go briefly how how we do it
so every indicator of subspace you just
end of some linear equations so it says
in AC 0 with motivates that's you just
take write the basis for the
perpendicular subspace and you check
that all the equations you need are
satisfied so maybe you need to add some
not yet so once you have this you just
need to sum all the subspaces right but
they're constantly many of them so just
you know you take the majority you check
them in whether they are more than 1 or
minus 1 or whatever but the important
part is that the number of bits in this
computation is just constant so no
matter how you do it you you get this
circuit with number of gates which is
again we said n is constant so it's some
constant times beaubien and the depth is
also like constant constant depends on
how do you implement this part but it's
it's constant so yeah so that's so
that's the first example I mean we said
we take function with small spectrum
normally I get something about this
circuit complexity so let's let's move
on to talk about this oh yeah
are there I I don't know there's anybody
oh no no it doesn't it doesn't know they
don't don't get ready buddy buddy yeah
but I thought the paper doesn't give any
as first but the majority is over I just
constantly many bits oh you mean this
so I didn't carefully analyze it might
be a larger constant that's what you
mean it's right right but yeah but it's
still a constant so no contacted me know
to get some mean under just if it's an
integer something they're disjoint no it
is plus and minus one they can they can
gain you can be canceled
all right so let's talk about decision
trees so this is like a definition by a
picture of what the decision tree is
it's just a tree on each a internal node
you query that variable if it's 0 you go
to the left sub the left subtree if it's
1 you go to the right subtree and then
on the leaves you have the values of the
function so this is a decision tree for
a majority of tree bits and you can just
check and obviously every function has
such a tree and it's it's like probably
the most simple computational model you
can think about but we're interested in
a generalization of a decision tree
which is a parity decision tree so now
we are we allow we're allowing every
internal node to query a linear function
of the inputs you just query Kyle 5x for
some alpha and if it's 1 you you branch
this way and if it's minus 1 you branch
that way or whatever so so this can be
much stronger like the XOR function you
would always need to query all of your
bits whereby if you're a line if you're
allowing yourself to make linear acquire
is it just in one query to compute the
XOR of n bits
so all right so it can be started and
stronger so here's just some of the
patients the D with this parity of f is
just a minimal death decision tree which
computes f and size with parity of f
that's minimal size of a parity decision
tree where we measure size by just the
number of leaves in the tree yeah so
it's not hard to figure out that if a
function is completely computed by a
parity decision tree which size s then
the l1 norm is at most s no sizes number
leaves yeah so the way you do it is you
just write your function as a sum of
indicators over the leaves of the tree
and it's such indicator that zero one
indicator so it has a spectrum someone
and you just use triangle inequality and
you get s and it can be they can be
quite far apart so for the end function
we said that the the l1 norm is at most
three but the size of the decision tree
is is at least n and you can you can do
like n were you the decision tree find
for example is depth end but it also
British it's the side is also n because
you have this have very unbalanced graph
right for n minus three so so that's
also the case for parity decision tree
you must start at least 10 queries so
the size also need to be on the graph of
n but so you can't really expect yeah so
so so we're looking at like
characterization of can can you compute
function with small spectral numbers by
small decision trees so you can't so
this gives you some limits to what you
can expect but and it's still pretty
small right this can be 2 to the N in
the general case so so here's what we do
know that if the l1 norm is at most M
then the size is this m to the M Squared
so again if M is constant and the size
is polynomial where generally it can be
exponential and the way to prove this
theorem is does this very lemma which
says that for any boolean function with
with l1 or M you can't find an ha ir
hyperplane just a restriction of episode
if you stick to f2 this hyperplane you
the spectral norm drops by something
significant so I'm going to state what I
want to say more precisely so so here's
the dilemma if the spectral norm is end
and you have your two largest
coefficient with the not value alpha and
beta and f KY of a plus beta equals Z
just to restriction to this hyperplane
then if you respect to kayfa plus beta
equals 1 then the specular norm drops by
M minus phat of alpha which is at most n
minus 1 over m and if you restrict to
minus 1 then it drops by the second
largest coefficient or or you it may be
that the roles are of 1 and minus 1 are
reversed so I I have it to that by a
picture so this is like a decision tree
parity decision tree picture of this
lemma you begin with a function with at
1 ohm M and you if you follow this path
you have a function with at 1 norm n
minus 1 over m and here so I didn't care
to to write all the details just what we
need
so here you have a function which
spectrum with most M so let's just give
the proof so what we wanted to prove is
this theorem so now the proof is just by
induction of M so each so you look at
like the worst case of n variables type
and variable function which I'm with M 1
or M and the key lemma just stated tells
you that if used if you query at the
root of your tree the two does
Kyah photos beta with alpha plus beta
being the two largest coefficient then
you get on one side a function on n
minus 1 variables with N 1 N 1 norm n
minus 1 over m and then on this side a
function with on n minus 1 variables
with at 1 on M so you just get this
inequality and you and you solve it and
that's what you get and if you're being
a little more careful if you also
consider the loss which is on this side
by the second largest coefficient then
you can even do a little bit better this
to G M Squared n to the M but it was it
would still be nice to say something
much better likely to give something
polynomial Boggan m and nm or to say
something meaningful
so in the case where m is polynomial in
N or or to show that you can't we don't
know so this is the decision tree the
parity decision new construction which
also gives you a formula so what's the
formula I'm just going to define it for
those unfamiliar with the lingo so our
formula is just a circuit with every
gate having out degree one so just an
example you have this boolean function
and how does the formula for it might
look so you take the end of x1 x2 and
now we end with XP and he take the end
of x1 x2 and then another explore and
the point here that you can't you can't
use the fact that you computed X 1 and X
2 over here in order to save up the
calculation over here you must redo the
calculation because you're you're you
have this property that every node as of
degree 1 so yeah so so so that's a
formula for boolean function which can
be larger than a circuit obviously so
yeah so we're not in my L of F it's just
the minimal size of the Morgan formula
which computes F so what the Morgan
formula is a formula where your gates
are finding 2 of N or in not for example
the xor function can be computed by form
enough of N squared so just like for
free when you have a decision tree you
get also a formula not too large the
size right if the parity decision tree
is s the subject I to the synthesize as
then the formula size at most s times I
squared so remember we had a bound on
this for function with small specks
unknown what about this so this is just
a short observation where you do an
induction S right you have this on the
root you have K gamma
and the function f left and f right this
is a linear function on X or F at most n
bits so so it's formula size is known to
be this is in fact their site this is
theta of N squared so if you write F
this way this Chi gamma and F or not
kite gamma and fr you get again this
recursive inequality what you just saw
so so what you get is that function with
small speck alone not only have small
circuits but also small formulas some of
the Morgan formulas so so again this is
the bound on the size of the decision
tree this is what you get when you
transfer it to a formula and and
formulas and which is so you can also
balance formula right you can always
make the depth pay that a lot of the
size of the formula so you also get a
bound on the depth of the formula so
obviously you can also think through the
previous construction using a green and
standard theorem you can also consider
what happens there when you construct a
formula and then the question is like
what values of M are you interested in
if M is constant then and over there you
have better balance but the moment F
becomes non constant then this this
might be really better and again we
would like to say something meaningful
when M is polynomial in n so in this
case both constructions are completely
useless it would be nice to to say
something or again to show that you
can't say anything
all right so so that concludes what I
had to say about function with small l1
norm let's move on to talk about spice
boolean function so this positive of a
function f oh yeah question yeah so for
proximation we do know that that if f as
again as 1 or M you can epsilon
approximate F by parity decision tree
with depth Oh M squared plus log 1 over
Epsilon no way but yeah but I don't know
when again anything about tightness of
this of this theorem but yeah and by
again by epsilon approximation I mean
that it is it agree it's a boolean the
purchase the soup she computes a boolean
function and it agrees with F and at
most but absent function of the inputs
that's the notion of approximation all
right so now I'm done with function with
small spectrum Norman let's move on to
talk about spice boolean function so
again so suppose it is just number of
nonzero Fourier coefficient here's a
notation this have had with 0 and again
just a random function would have almost
all of them nonzero so you expect a
spice function to be special in several
ways and again if F is computed by pair
to decision tree with depth D and size s
then there are
this posited at most s times 2 to the D
which is most for you today and this is
again the same the same proof by writing
your functions or some indicators of the
leaves of the tree so here's an example
of splice function it's called the
address function so your input is just
log in bits X 1 + 2 X log N and then
another n bits y1 to yn and your output
is the Y variable which is indexed by
the X variable right this gives you an
index between 1 to N and the value of
the function is just the Y variable
which whose address appears in this box
so this is a function over n plus log
and variables and it's pass it is N
squared which is very small compared to
2 to the N and it's also quite able to
see this this function is computed by by
a small decision tree but you need to
query the bits the X bits and then
there's only another relevant variable
the why the why will a bit that you need
to query and then you know the value of
the function so so this leads to this
conjecture that there is some constancy
with every boolean function f the parity
decision feed depth of F is at most a
lot positi to this constant C so let me
try to give some motivation for this
conjecture well one motivation is that
like we all know like ten boolean
functions right and all of them problems
through you know but another motivation
comes from communication complexity so
I'm just going to quickly go over why
this communication complexity so we have
a function f from 0 1 to the N cross 0 n
to the N to 0 1 a boolean function you
have our Alice on one side with X
with the other side on why and you want
to compute f of x and y so so they talk
to each other right I mean unless f is a
really simple vena stopped to compute
this function and the deterministic
communication complexity of F is just
the minimal number of bits they need to
communicate in order to compute F so I'm
going to consider in our deterministic
protocols then not allowed to flip coins
they must be always correct and this is
the communication complexity of F so
just observe that if you have a parity
decision before F with depth D then that
gives you a particle with two times D
bits right because on every node you
have this Union function on your
variable so just some model with two of
the X variables and the sum of the two
of the Y variables so a nice computer
sound Bob computes his sound they just
exchange the outcomes they determine
this sum and they just move along the
three right they speak to each other so
that begins to show us why is this even
relevant so now for every function I ask
you construct this matrix M F with these
two to the N times to the N and every
entry of M F indexed by x and y is just
capital capital f of x and y and then it
is one known ever since before I was
born that the communication complexity
of F is at least the logarithm of the
rank of n F and it is conjectured that
it is political rhythmic in the rank of
and F and that is called the Lord Ram
conjecture its major open problem but
now so your function is of this very
special special type f of x and y is
just this lower case F evaluated at X X
or Y for some boolean function
so yeah those are called xor functions
so we're not again in there in the
general setting where you're allowed any
function from 0 1 to the N cross the 1
to the end we're just looking at Excel
functions and now if you if you
construct this matrix and then the
eigenvector is just the Fourier
characters and the eigenvalues would be
the Fourier coefficients
so the rank of M F is just the sparsity
of F of that little F so again this is a
1 do the calculation but this is just 1
9 2 2 to be convinced that the case so
so if this conjecture which I started
with is true if the parity decision tree
depth of F is part logarithmic in the
Fourier space day then you would prove
that the log rank conjecture holds for
the special case of Excel functions
right because we saw that given a parity
decision tree you get practical and and
this protocol cost would be poly log in
this positon which is poly log in the
rank of capital F so that's I mean
obviously that's not an if and only if I
mean it can be that you could find other
protocols for extra function which are
not based on parity decision trees but
that's perhaps one way to prove it
so I'll just comment that the best
separation we know between those two
equalities is a function f whose parity
decision tree is at least the logarithm
of this possibility there 1.63 so this
this this poly log cannot be it can be
like with C equals 1 right there is
nothing but they must be some some
separation so this is the same function
you construct for those of you notice to
to separate the log rank from the
communication complexity deterministic
communication complexity and you get
your log six to the base 3 which is one
point six three again this is a very
nice construction of a boolean function
I won't get into the details because I
don't have much time but but that what
it gives you so let's let's figure out
figure out how would we prove this
theory I mean what happens to the
Fourier transform of f when you restrict
to this hyperplane so now you look at
your subspace model you alpha right you
have before restriction you have hold of
the F curve for your coefficient and now
you look module alpha right here so so
every such two coefficient like I've had
a beta 1 F hat of beta 1 plus alpha we
just collapse to to the single
coefficient we've had Bay 1 plus F hat
of beta 1 plus alpha N and so on for
every pair which is which equals ma
alpha so so obviously what we would like
to show and we want to test positive the
drop would well want to find such alpha
where check which we have many pairs
collapsing to do the same to the same
coefficient many pairs in the support
now obviously it for example if I could
find one that always cuts the support by
half then that would be great but but
but I know I can't because of the
separation we we just said so yeah so we
want to find such album which would
collapse many together but we don't know
how many we can even hope for but let's
consider the special case where F has
both small spectral norm and boats
especially the small small sparsity
that's like I'm being very greedy in my
demands but now we know that the parity
decision tree depth of F is at most M
squared times log s so again if M is
constant or even part logarithmic in F
that's this conjecture is true and I'm
just so I think that's the paper of
human was mentioning by Zhang Wang XI
and Junction they show independently
that you can even take it to be
and log s so let's let's show the proof
it's not done it's not hard so remember
this key lemma I had that says we can
find an hyperplane which reduces the
specter norm to be n minus 1 over m so
if we just apply it you know M squared
times we get an offensive spaced with Co
dimension at most x squared where F is
constant right because it can't go with
a 1 so I'm starting with M and just skip
keep scraping off this one over m of the
spectrum normal after at most M Squared
restriction I'm going to get to a
constant function so nuts so yeah so so
just you know we are M to M Squared you
know function that you can fix them in a
way that F is now a constant that's the
theorem so now let's let's think about
this P I'm just on the ice level I'm
wearing Chi Alpha I wear these are those
specially in your function so I know
there exists one path on which the
function is constant right that's that's
the theorem so let's try to think what
would happen on any other path of this
tree so now when I came is that since
here the function is constant then in
fact every nonzero coefficient had to
cancel out right with another
coefficient otherwise the function would
have an non constant Fourier coefficient
and it would not be constant but the
fact that they did cancel out
specifically means that they collapsed
again to the same to the same
coefficient so it doesn't matter which
way I mean which values I restrict Chi
Alpha is it only matters which function
I restrict right so because if you if
you restrict there is exist some values
beta the TP was tweaked f to those
values you get a constant function so
again for every nonzero f have a beta
there must exist some nonzero have had a
beta plus gamma with gamma in this this
span of these vectors for them to cancel
out
right because again you look at your
cell face model ooh of 1 to alpha and
squared so that's exactly what we wanted
right we said we want to sew again so
I've had a beta F at beta plus gamma
would collapse to the same coefficient
so to you you would cut the support by
at least two right for any values beta
prime I you would select the spacing the
freest past it is is it most half of
what you begin with let's let's go back
to the diagram maybe right so here I
know I'm constant but here I know that
the worst thing that attack can happen
is that I have a function which have
this partially so I made some some
progress right and after it must log log
s steps we get a constant function and
all leaves so in fact so so what was
important about the argument was finding
this large subspace right I didn't care
what would what it is but so you can
fact that the same proof shows that if
you want to prove that the parity
decision tree depth is poly logarithmic
and the dispositive that it's enough to
prove this conjecture that for everybody
a function f is a subspace with
codimension poly log of this party on
which F is constant because then you
would do the exact same proof right and
you get a higher exponent but still
something poly logarithmic in s so so I
just want here this I mean obviously
this implies this right because this
tells you that's on all paths or you
have a constant function is this just
just this one just are required to find
one path so so those are in fact
equivalent conjecture and and again we
don't we don't know what's what how to
prove its
so so let's just summarize what what we
had
so about function with small speck along
we have we know many things we know
again they have small circuit small
formula small compared to this injury
and I didn't I didn't show it but it's
also true today they also have small
randomized communication complexity and
then by result of the VIN scale of it so
you also have small deterministic
communication complexity
so the log rank conjecture which is
simple which we talked about is true for
function with concert secular norm and
yeah and spice functions are you yeah
it's much more mysterious than and those
types of function so we mainly have I
mean you have open problems and not much
progress over there so no I don't know
yeah so what what oh so it's exactly the
same trick this main main lemma trick
that you again own every node you just
query
Kyah Kyah box braid our f alpha and F
that was was an F at beta at the two
largest coefficient and you do this
recursively and then you just observe
that if you stop after this number of
levels and you you have this so fun
every after this number of levels you
may you may have a leaf with a function
which is in not constant right some sub
function some restriction of F but you
just drowned every such leaf to the like
the majority or if it's balanced just
big or whatever and then you show that
that's an epsilon approximation for it